[Music]
alarms there's the ones that wake you up
in the morning tell you you've got a
message that your lunch is ready to
close the fridge door emails phone calls
Skype calls Facebook message turbulence
and below and one particular researcher
has created this an alarm to stand out
from the crowd an alarm to stop a
head-on car collision her name is Carol
Baldwin and she's I am the director of
the human factors in applied cognition
program at George Mason University so
how do you go about creating one of the
world's most annoying sounds we started
out by going out and getting recordings
of actual sounds that were in
automobiles currently then we took those
sounds back to the lab once they
collected the sounds it was time to test
on people they created a system where
the listener could play a sound and then
put it in a category that the sound was
represented either a low urgency like a
facebook notification a medium range
urgency like a check engine alert and
finally a high level urgency like an
oncoming collision warning
and then from there we set up a series
of driving simulator studies and they're
driving along and they're doing another
task just to kind of give them a
distraction component and then suddenly
unexpectedly car that they're following
would break suddenly and we looked at
their collision avoidance response on
the timing of that they created the
perfect forward collision warning alarm
and this is really important because we
found that the sounds being used
currently weren't perceived as being
very urgent
you know a poorly designed sound can be
more dangerous than not having the
warning at all so thanks for using the
most annoying sound to keep the anechoic
chamber is a test lab for doing acoustic
testing it's a chamber within a chamber
who is in a chamber that's Steve I'm
Steve Warfield the founder of Warfield
laboratories in Minneapolis and we're
talking about what it feels like to sit
in one of the quietest rooms on earth an
aniconic chamber is a room that absorbs
sound so it's quiet with subjects in the
anechoic chamber to sit them in a chair
and we turn off the lights it turns out
that the only noises you'd hear in there
are noises that come from inside your
own body right away you'll usually hear
the sounds of your ears buzzing you'll
start to hear the joints in your arms
and in your legs like the sound of
rubbing two pieces of wood together
[Music]
you don't clearly hear your heart
beating kind of a the flow of the air
into your lungs and sounds from inside
your body that you might have heard
outside the chamber or suddenly so much
louder any noise that would be startling
outside the chamber would be 16 times
the star's light inside the chamber
noises like your stomach growling or
your knuckles cracking people don't last
that long inside maybe an hour and 15
minute and that's mainly because of one
of two reasons some people find that
very relaxing some people find that
fearful or claustrophobic
one person's peace and quiet is
another's personal nightmare
[Music]
here we are in the whole Valley rain
forest
this is a cathedral lie
in this forest is the quietest place in
the entire United States and it's only
one square inch of the size my mission
is to keep it that way
I'm Gordon Hempton I'm a sound tracker I
travel the globe in search of vanishing
sounds including the most endangered of
all which is simply silence noise
pollution is nearly enix capable the
whole valley is the quietest least noise
polluted place in the entire lower 48 I
don't know if I can save silence but I
know that I can try so it was 12 years
ago 2005 Earth Day that I hiked up the
HOH River Valley it took 3 miles just to
escape the notice of the parking lot
that's when I was looking in every
direction for which way I should go
I saw the elk trail love to follow their
advice because they loved quiet just
like I do
and they led me right to the spot I
defend this one square inch of silence
by doing both quiet and noise monitoring
when a noise intrusion occurs I locate
the noise maker send them a letter and
ask for compliance this matter is urgent
within 10 years it's likely that there
will be no quiet places left unless we
take action when I first started I did
not think silence would go extinct in my
lifetime and if that happens the quiet
will disappear and the wildlife will be
devastated
the one square inch of silence
foundation is pressing our politicians
to pass a single piece of legislation
that will designate Olympic National
Park as the world's first quiet park
off-limits to aircraft all things are
possible the earth is here and it's
beautiful and for me it all starts here
in the whole valley pops I just write I
Nicole Paris the princess beatboxing is
just simply making sounds with your
mouth making music with your mouth when
beatbox came to st. Louis in the early
80s it was always about emulating what
the DJ did so I just thought of
perfecting my skill as I got older and
then my wife she gets pregnant with
Nicole so I would be box up against the
building and nikolas thought twisting so
you will see my wife's belly almost like
boom she liked that she thought it was
funny and cute and then to ask Nicole
got bigger in the belly it wasn't cute
no more at the age of 13 was my first
talent show I just went home and I said
pops are just going to talent show you
want to teach me how to be box he taught
me how to hold of my Tommy
breathe taught me the basic beat I went
to the town show did that they made me
mad at the talent show they was clapping
offbeat and it was like I then started
to add my own thing to what he taught me
one night I came home from work and as
I'm walking in the door I heard her
making all these strange noise I had to
tell her like that's not beatboxing I
don't do that that's corny I like what
this is when I had to realize and tell
myself look this is what she wants to do
man possibly be box anywhere all day
don't even know if we really known we'd
be box my cooking barbershop when we're
ready to beatbox it literally happens
doesn't matter if you go to her YouTube
challenge you will see us sitting down
beatboxing it's yourself function it can
look like a competition we're not really
battling it's just it's just jam session
just us having fun this this is how I
bonded my track even though she loves
pop loser I want her to be the best I
want her to to outdo me not in outdo me
like as in a paddle but I want her to
just just continue to grow and add to
beatboxing
[Music]
I would like to walk down the red carpet
and have the interviewers talk to me
about the choices that I made creatively
as opposed to hey you're female like
yeah and having been in a band I was
recording things and they weren't coming
out right and that was it I wanted to be
in control of what it sounded like
Emily Lazar is a mastering engineer and
it's most basic a mastering engineer
takes either stereo or multi-channel
audio and prepares it for distribution
whether that be making it sound the best
on the piece of vinyl on Spotify one
mastering approach doesn't always work
for all of those different things but
she isn't just any mastering engineer
she is the first woman to ever be
nominated in the category of Best
engineered album non-classical when that
first Grammy nomination where I was in
for the first woman for album of the
year I was like completely in shock and
so I started you know trying to look
online to see if I could figure out if
that was actually true because I
couldn't be in my mind it just couldn't
be mastering the mastering industry
doesn't always save you from the
inevitable being female and being in
audio in the first place was a complete
oddity there sexism there's ageism
there's there's all sorts of things that
happen and we're in a culture now where
you can speak out I was not allowed
really to speak out before I also had
situations where I had people inject me
into a situation because I was a woman
because they thought that that was like
a cool thing to have a woman and she was
also equally as despicable these things
happened and I'm aware that they happen
but they did not get my attention they
did not suck me down and I always try to
inspire not just women to follow their
dreams I really believe that if you can
see it and make it happen it happens and
if you only see all the negative stuff
all the people who don't want women or
don't treat you like an equal or
whatever then you're gonna spend your
life kind of focusing on on that and I
don't have time for that I don't have
room for that I have want to make
records and I don't want to talk about
why I can't
[Music]